what i love about your show is that it
takes place in i think 1973
and that's when i'm growing up coming of
age and the 70s it's very hard to
explain to people it was a different
time it was a very different time yeah
you could like i don't know it wasn't
cell phone cameras and you could just
like i mean
weren't video games yet really yeah
there was no internet you just like
played with matches or like threw rocks
in people's pools
right did you guys not grow up like that
either yeah
yeah it's just stuff like that i
remember uh i'm one time climbing up a
tree with a friend of mine and just
these big kids came by and started
throwing rocks at us
until we cried and then they left
and then we went down we climbed down
and we started like lighting the woods
on fire like this is what kids did in
the 70s they did
thank god for cell phones they're gone
for video games firecrackers messed
around with firecrackers yeah we tied a
kid to a tree one time we threw
fireworks at him you threw fire you tied
a kid with tree and fireworks out and he
thought it was funny at first and then
we got like carried away and then there
were the quick wick ones and one of my
buddies instead of throwing it like that
he went like this and it blew up in his
hand
and he just pulled right see this is why
i'm animating this because my entire
career all of my jokes you know if i
i've always been like oh what does that
say that's going to make kids do this so
we're going to animate it and then
nobody can get offended except for
parents of animated kids